okay we are here on overtime and let me
ask the quit Rob Reider what do you hope
your movie being Charlie will contribute
to the national discussion on drug abuse
well just that I mean just that to have
part be part of the discussion I mean
you know it's it's become an epidemic of
drug abuse well it is yeah I mean and
we've seen it now because it's kind of
infiltrated into the white suburban
communities well now all of a sudden
become yeah scription drugs is becoming
a big thing it's on all the you know
it's a big issue in all the campaign's
so it hopefully will be part of that
discussion actually I don't know why
they don't talk about it more because it
is a bigger they did that is a white
America issue
I mean heroin is exploding in the white
game absolutely because it's cheaper
it's a lot cheaper than the prescription
drug yeah you know and that's that's
what's happened it's personal I saw my
neighbor not off on the lawnmower the
other day yeah I'll tell you it's really
getting bad when that happens boy
landscape okay any ideas who the
Republican and Democratic frontrunner
will pick as their VP's I guess we're at
that stage already I I keep saying I
want Hillary to pick Elizabeth Warren
that would seal the deal
never shadows I would be the glue
sherrod Brown it could be you know yeah
yeah no but you would like it was a
Republican replace if she's smarter
about this republic doubling down or we
get the base out he's the other gonna be
out is gonna be when Donald if Donald
Trump is the nominee the base how
Matthew and the crew here you don't have
to some Bernie voters are gonna vote for
Trump thank you they only based on trade
based on outsider about why no money in
politics same beaut rising Hillary is
more nervous about Bernie voters right
now she was about Trump voters I mean I
think she is going to I mean I think as
this thing plays out she was going to be
catering to them more and more I don't
think she's just gonna go away
no no but the bigger question is who
would want to be Trump's VP
chris Christie that's the quest for any
people right chris Christie he'll line
up it'll be people everyone needs an act
I mean it's like it would be a perfect
all those quislings have already come
aboard chris Christie Sarah Palin uh
dr. wolf a scary fear doctor gentle ben
Carson is already Wayne to be a good
environmentalist or animal rights
activist is it essential to give up meat
entirely well we raise for too many
animals for food as 9 billion a year the
average American eats 30 animals per
year the global figure is 77 billion so
with 7 billion people that's 11 animals
per per person we've got a small planet
that's 70% covered by water of the
terrestrial landscape a bunch of it is
rock and ice and desert the habitable
portion is limited animals you know take
enormous inputs of grain and water I
mean we can't afford it I did an event
with Mark Bittman the other night former
New York Times food columnist he said if
the rest of the world adopts our habits
on meat eating we will need for Earth's
oh yeah now we're we're cook yeah and
plus I mean when you have this many
animals then you're raising them in
these horrific factories yeah plus the
methane the met right people don't talk
about that in terms of the greenhouse
gas emissions issue animal agriculture
is the number two source in the world
right I mean its enormous 18 percent I
mean the head of the UN program on this
says you know we need to start thinking
about our diet I mean if we have a
meatless Monday program just do it once
a week even if you could reduce it by
15% which is one day a week that would
be an enormous be 1.5 billion animals
that you don't really you're a vegan I'm
a vegan yeah when I was a when I'm sad
you won't he said he looks very healthy
yeah when I was a little Catholic boy
you know and do it yeah when I was a
little Catholic boy uh you know we never
thought about eating meat on Friday
because you just didn't do it right but
you know and of course in those days you
wouldn't even vegetarianism didn't know
well my book no you had fish right now
we're killing all the fish but if we
could just replace start with that well
also you know I in my military in my
book I talk about these plant-based
proteins I mean people are melding food
and technology and we're seeing
plant-based proteins are gonna mimic all
the qualities of chicken and pork about
the same taste a taste just like Jake's
and there's a it's just like chicken
and it sounds crazy and futuristic but I
visited a guy who's doing lab based meat
I mean we grow cells for insulin to deal
with diabetes we grow cells for organs
why can't we grow tissue if we want that
I mean it sounds absurd but a smart
phone probably sounded absurd 19 right
did you eat the blab blab I did I did
taste so I guess I may not be a vegan
after that but yeah it was just like
beef jerky you know I don't think beef
jerky is gonna excite your palate very
much but it was okay people love beef
jerky you know loves it the room yeah
slim jims on the checkout though exactly
it's an impulse walk I wasn't thinking
about it yeah it's right next to this
well the violence of protests outside
recent Trump events have an impact on
his campaign or rhetoric I mean I think
already the threat of riots at the
convention which he put out there has
had an effect because the people who are
voting the people the delegates they're
the ones are gonna be at that convention
they don't want to riot well fairly or
unfairly you can draw a straight line
from Donald Trump's dissent among female
voters to the March 11th rally in
Chicago which he canceled and then he
retweeted Heidi Cruz's picture like he
wasn't doing as poorly among women
before all of that and now you see the
city of Cleveland I believe has bought
extra riot insurance they're getting
ready for what may or may not happen but
um this is you know that's not looking
forward to it I'm in 68 right I wasn't
there I was three years old oh no that
was it was it-- it was rough well yeah
well I wasn't fair but I yeah I was of
age it right but that was different 68
was Democrats fighting with in their
universe I mean the Trump protests were
mainly Democrats I mean it was black
lives matter and it was other folks who
don't like well broad but he was talking
about if he doesn't get the nomination
oh yeah his brown shirt we're gonna yes
they're gonna get very upset and then
you know I I'm not saying I'm before
riots I'm just saying it's gonna happen
and the media will be right there no
there is no scenario in which Trump
doesn't win the nomination and then goes
away quietly and get out
justbe option endorses Cruz or her we're
back never ever gonna go so good
nominate him or nothing our calls for a
third-party candidate to enter the race
likely to garner any real movement I
think that's a great way to stop Trump
what put up put somebody up there who
will siphon off enough votes I think
that's the only way I won't even you
guaranteed yeah actually I think a lot
of Hillary voters or not
Bernie voters even would love a place to
go that is not Hillary and I think
unfortunately for that idea the time to
do that was two months ago and and that
whatever the never to remember is
thinking of that it wasn't it was yeah
it just but there was just no movement
on it was great you know if you want to
stop Trump I mean Hillary is going to
beat him I mean that's what every every
high people saying Matt it's not us he
is every poll shows this come on you're
Jewish you don't believe in ken ahora
Indian because when is when you say
something don't say this as logic behind
it if you if you make them complacent
that the election is in the bag they are
not gonna come out to vote and it is not
in the bag I don't put anything past
this stupid country including voting for
jumping I remember when they were
laughing at the prospect of Ronald
Reagan but the man was governor of
California once everyone's been able to
predict anything here one of the things
that they know what's gonna happen is on
some time he can't he can't right step
and it's April you can't with the polls
he nothing has Trump keep saying himself
I haven't even started on Hillary yeah
but you can't run for president by going
down the list of American ethnic groups
and insulting them all in turn it just
doesn't work we'll see because everybody
predicted the stroke was going to
implode 20 times within the Republican
primary was a tiny rise or a severe to
what we're talking this is it I mean the
other thing the notion the 50,000
Pennsylvanians who krauser with me
that's it that's the scary number for
Hillary the [ __ ] elect people how much
do you hate yet listen four years
starting in 1960 we with the exception
of 72 we always went for the president
look
that we saw is more inspirational
forward-looking just pleasure and now
you know it's hard to know who's among
the five that are left who is that this
time really seriously everybody is
prophesying gloom and doom it's really
not about energizing your base so much
as hating on them not John wait a minute
wait a minute a basic exercise asana if
he isn't real Hilary's not prophesizing
us say what is already great well you
know Hillary's the one who said we don't
have to make America great again America
is closed yes America is great she says
we don't we're not put my boy tearing
down don't thank you by the way no that
is itself a sign of weakness that she is
running as a candidate of complacency
which is not a good thing to be doing
right so why are you saying it's in the
bag it's not in the bag have a good